of the 50
thanks for coming on such short notice
small fires I can put out on my own but
this is above my pay grade what's the
problem exactly
fires literally also they're finding out
the kombucha is dirty seawater well the
timing worked out it just wrapped up
award season would you read black people
all of them who's a really good year
listen babe baby babe stay in the tent
okay your pulse rate should be there in
about 45 minutes it's some purge
going on right now so lay low please hey
guys this is Vanessa I'm here to help
oh my god let's all just calm down okay
we can fix this you'll be my tracker
first things first
I booked a new lineup for weekend to
puddle of mud String Cheese Incident the
sloppy sandwiches even if the band's
don't show you're still honoring your
contract did this happen so we were
going to be wife and Ebro kind of drug
bro you do not have a drug problem
every possible weathers for a jinx I was
at Coachella back in oh seven it was
like a level out there so his live said
is really searched everything was
accounted for
look here yeah this is just a bunch of
stick figures with erections look we can
still turn this thing around well spin
weekend one as a giant escape room
experience in the Bahamas don't get
eaten it's authentic we'll say the other
festivals are too corporate
and this is what Burning Man was 20
years ago is there a way we can spin
this for if you don't like the festival
you're racist so homophobic amazing I'll
write it down next to the dicks okay
let's put a leaky pipeline through the
middle of festival grounds like I didn't
Dakota people love that do they have
Zika out there I left the again we could
just say it was a group hallucination I
love it I can't I'm sorry
hey guys
North Korea just launched a nuke in LA
now you saw that ah
so let